and her husband shakuru took us to where
they buried their newborn son just a few
hours before we met them
they said they fled their Village last
week when the M23 Rebel group bombed it
walked for three days sleeping rough on
the roadside to reach here
the child was very tired in my womb
because of the days I spent on the road
my pregnancies started feeling very bad
then yesterday I gave birth but the
child passed away today
their son just 10 hours old he's one of
the youngest to die in the conflict
between Congolese government forces and
M23 widely understood to be a proxy of
neighboring Rwanda although Rwanda
denies it
this is their new home among many new
arrivals at this camp for displaced
people on the outskirts of the city of
Goma
Florence bijohike showed us where people
are sleeping
she was a farmer and a community health
worker until she fled the fighting
earlier this year
she told us 22 children have died here
and eight women have had miscarriages in
the last 10 days
we're fleeing the bombs getting tired on
the road and sleeping Outdoors so you
have babies stillborn some miscarriages
are the direct consequence of the trauma
from being bombed by the rebels some are
dying in their sleep just a few days
after being born because of living in
such bad conditions
there isn't enough food to eat many
people here are surviving on just one
meal a day and the shelters aren't
adequate it's raining heavily almost
every day here at the moment some people
were given a plastic sheet by the
government others told us they had to
sell it just to be able to afford food
so they've made shelters from leaves and
sticks instead there isn't enough clean
water to drink and there are tens of
thousands of families here struggling in
these conditions with hardly any help
Congo's Army says its new offensive will
help it lost ground to M23 over the last
year now it's pushing back bombing Rebel
positions with fighter jets and attack
helicopters
M23 wrote in a statement that it's the
airstrikes that are displacing people
everyone we spoke to here said they ran
in fear before that as soon as the
rebels came close
M23 are widely known for forcing
civilians to fight or work and for
killing them if they don't
nobody here knows if or when it will be
safe enough to go home
in the meantime they desperately need
help
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Gomer Democratic
Republic of Congo